what is this oh
here more food for Hunter hey what is
this bit dude oh I see okay now this is
the McDonald's I like okay
is this a nice Coca-Cola over here
okay
if the camera's telling me do I'll be
[__] pissed take a couple swings of
that of this yeah no I've never seen you
drink regular Coke drink just drink a
little bit of the regular Coke it's
either you take off those shoes and you
show them your feet
Hunter wants to see my feet so bad dude
you know when you're when you're gonna
where the [__] are you putting the coke
over there
do an impression of what you think I
sound like actually
dude it's a huge
God all I hear in the back is just Jesus